[موسيقى]
الناتو يحشد 360 الف جندي في حدود روسيا
وموسكو منظومه الناتو باكملها تحاربا
ولدينا ما يكفي لحل الامر عسكريا وللمره
الثانيه بولندا تنشر الاف الجنود بالقرب
من جيرانها والدفاع الروسيه توضح السبب
وبوتين يضع قانونا جديدا لحاله التاهب
القصوى والطوارئ بعيدا عن اوروبا والامم
المتحده فما الذي يجري الجيش الاوكراني
باغت نظيره الروسي
والفط نهر دن وفضيحه اوروبيه بامداد كياف
باسلحه تالفه وبسبب الصين واشنطن تمنع
الامارات من سلاح قوي فرنسا تشعل فتيل
الحرب في النيجر ومقاومه جديده تتشكل
السعوديه تضع شروطها للاعتراف باسرائيل
وايران تدخل نادي الصواريخ الاسرع من
الصوت حرب جديده تطبخ على نار هادئه خطوه
الجيش العسكري تسجل المكان واصواتهم تعلو
اكثر فاكثر ولا صوت يعلو فوق صوت قعقعه
البنادق لتعلن بولندا وللمره الثانيه انها
ستنشر الفي جندي اضافي عند الحدود مع
بيلاروسيا سعيا منها لايقاف تقدم فاغنر
ولمواجهه محاوله مهاجرين عبور الحدود
باعداد قياسيه ليخرج وزير الدفاع الروسي
سيرجيو مسرحا بانه سيتم نشر قوات اضافيه
على الحدود الغربيه لروسيا وهناك كشف
شويغو ان حوالي 360 الف عسكريا اوروبي
ينتشرون على مقربه من حدود دوله الاتحاد
التي تضم روسيا وبيلاروسيا مضيفا ان هناك
ثمانيه الاف عربه مدرعه وسته الاف مدفع
و650 مقاتله ومروحيه يا الهي ما كل هذه
الاعداد هل يتحضرون لحرب قادمه وكالعاده
المصدر هو من يتحدث وكما هو امامكم في
موقع سبوتنك العالمي ليتهم
بتحضير خطط لاحتلال اجزاء من غرب اوكرانيا
فما كل تلك الجلبه على الحدود بين بولندا
وليتوانيا واوكرانيا وكذلك روسيا
وبيلاروسيا هل حان للحرب ان تخرج بعيدا عن
اوكرانيا الامر لم يتوقف عند هذا الحد
ليخرج نائب رئيس مجلس الامن القومي ديما
تريما ويقول ان منظومه الناتو باكملها
عمليا تحارب ضدنا بشكل علني ولكن لدينا ما
يكفي من لحل جميع مسائل العمليه العسكريه
وفق تعبيره اما شويغو فعاد واشار الى ان
اوكرانيا تسلمت من الغرب مئات الدبابات
والاف المدرعات واكثر من 1200 مدفعه
وعشرات من انظمه الدفاع الجوي بقيمه فاقت
160 مليار دولار وهنا ننتقل الى الميدان
حيث تشتد المعارف ضراوه فقد اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه استمرار تقدم الجيش الروسي
وتعزيز نقاطه التكتيكيه في مقاطعه
شرق اوكرانيا والقضاء على 795 جنديا
اوكرانيا على مختلف المحاور وفي ارقام
كهذه العهده على المصدر وها نحن نتصفحه
امامكم في الموقع الرسمي للحكومه الروسيه
تضيف الوزاره الروسيه انها احبطت محاوله
اوكرانيه لتنفيذ هجوم بواسطه مسيرتين على
العاصمه موسكو وضواحيها وعلى الجانب
الاوكراني قالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه
ان القوات الروسيه شنت هجمات بصاروخ مجنح
ونفذت 53 غاره جويه خلال الاربع والعشرين
ساعه كما اطلقت 86 مقذوفا من راجمات
الصواريخ ما ادى الى مقتل واصابه عدد من
المدنيين والحاق اضرار بمنشات مدنيه واخرى
للبنيه التحتيه واشارت الى ان طائره
الاوكرانيه نفذت 10 غارات على مواقع
القوات الروسيه الاركان اكدت ان قواتها
صدت هجمات الروسيه في مقاطعه
بمقاطعه سابوريجيا ردك جاء بتاكيد الجيش
الاوكراني ان قوته نفذت عمليه خاصه وخاطفه
في معقل القوات الروسيه بالضفه الجنوبيه
لنهر ودمرت مركزا للقياده الروسيه بها مما
اسفر عن مقتل عدد كبير من الجنود الروس
فالمقابل اعلنت القوات المواليه لروسيا في
خراس عن افشال هذه العمليه الاوكرانيه هذا
يؤكد وذاك ينفي ونحن ناتيكم بالمصدر يكون
الجيش الاوكراني ان قواته نفذت عمليه خاصه
في معقل القوات الروسيه بالمنطقه ودمرت
مركز للقياده الروسيه هناك ما اسفر عن
مقتل عدد كبير من الجنود الروس اعلنت
القوات المواليه لروسيا فيخرسون انها
افشلت هذا الانزال ولا زلنا على الارض
ولكن في الاراضي الروسيه هذه المره بعد
وقوع انفجار في منطقه سيراكيف باصاد التي
تبعد حوالي 70 كيلومترا شمال الشرقي موسكو
نقلت وكاله تاسع عن خدمات الطوارئ الروسيه
ان الانفجار في مصنع زاكورسك في موسكو ليس
ناتجا عن هجومه بطائره مسيره لنستمر ايضا
من روسيا حيث احال الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين الى مجلس الدومه مشروع قانون يتيح
لروسيا عدم ابلاغ مجلس اوروبا والامم
المتحده باعلان حاله الطوارئ على اراضي
روسيا وبالعوده الى اوكرانيا فقد كشف تاجر
سلاح ان دوله اوروبيه اشترت عشرات من
الدبابات المستعمله طراز ليوبارد واحد
لصالح اوكرانيا ما شكل صدمه للقوات
الاوكرانيه التي كانت تنتظر اسلحه حديثه
وذكرت رويترز ان ضبابه ليوباردي الالمانيه
الصنع كانت محل جدال في وقت سابق من هذا
العام بعد ان قال وزير الدفاع البلجيكي
ان الحكومه بحثت اعاده شراء دبابات
ارسالها لاوكرانيا لكن تقارير نقلت عنه
بالقول ان الاسعار غير معقوله مستعمله
وباسعار مرتفعه وكيا هي من ستسدد الفاتوره
اليس كذلك الاحداث والتطورات افادت صحيفه
متردده في مساله تزويد الامارات بمقاتله
اف 35 بسبب مخاوف من امكانيه نقل تقنيات
سريه الى الصين الى النيجر حيث اتخذ قاده
الانقلاب العسكري في النيجر اجراءات
امين
التي منحتها لهم للتراجع عن الانقلاب
والافراج عن الرئيس المحتجاز في المقابل
تم تاسيس مجلس مقاومه في النيجر هذا
المجلس ضع
الجنود شعب الى انهاء التمرد والمضي دون
تاخير في اعتقال الجنرال تشياني وبعد
تاسيس هذا المجلس فنحن امام مجلسين احدهما
عسكري انقلابي والاخر يسمي نفسه مقاومه
فهل ينفخ الغرب في نار الفتنه بين
المجلسين في ذات السياق اعلن المجلس
العسكري ان قوات الجيش الفرنسي قامت بخرق
المجال الجوي المغلقي للبلاد حيث هاجمت
مواقعا للقوات المسلحه فالنيجر لتحليل
حلفائه الارهابيين اوردت وكاله تسنيم
الايرانيه ان طهران نجحت في تصنيع
[موسيقى]